-And finally, I know a lot of
people find math boring.
Well, that's why we've updated
math to make the equations
about stuff
that you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics."
♪♪
-♪ Popular mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Let's take a look at
our first equation here.
If you take clogs
plus a hole punch
equals Crocs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Popular mathematics.
-Very popular.
-So, if you take Bill Clinton
plus nothing to do
plus a heat wave, plus 100
equals the Billboard Hot 100.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow. Bill Bored. Hot 100.
-If you take The Penguin...
-Right.
-...plus six pints of Guinness,
it equals the Boston Celtics
mascot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How about this one?
Here's a "kiss the chef" apron
plus a complaint to HR,
equals "firm handshake the chef"
apron.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you take Cheetos
plus Chachi...
-Uh-oh.
-...plus chicken plus euphoria
it equals Ch-Ch-Ch-Chia.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, if you take
a Twinkie plus googly eyes
plus $4 billion,
it equals the Minions franchise.
There you have it.
That's all the time we have
for "Popular Mathematics."